and you guys are already responsible
right you're already disciplining with
money you're not wasting your very I
mean to a deep to a fault you your
frugal really know do you or you got
that figured out okay it's like the
English the English have conservative
figured out yeah now they need to go
back to being you know loud and
obnoxious
the Americans have obnoxious yeah you
guys kind of work but but compared to
them right compared to the English
proper yeah but it's working
what's the target children people yeah
okay
all right sounds good but I thought the
target was 100 million yeah a year yeah
okay but if collaboration got you there
the target is the gross you know if
there's enough gross thanks again if
there's enough gross there's enough
gross you make money working to do 150
million bucks this year would you rather
be a 150 million dollars for 12 million
dollars what will net probably just
under 30 percent of that but but dude I
could make it make I could make sense of
saying I'm not gonna need anything I'm
just gonna use it I'm just gonna use it
to like like make my next move cuz my
ideas not to make 150 million I'm like
okay how do i scale this thing up now to
500 hopefully hopefully you're always
looking to grow it otherwise you're
gonna otherwise we know how this story
ends
I'm just trying to save my bathwater you
know the way the way we're used to three
kids three kids would take you know a
bath in the same bathwater yeah
very very accurate channels yeah cuz you
don't trust it you don't trust this yeah
you don't trust yourself that's why
you're like okay don't don't spend
anything
I understand whether he's Thomas I
understand you know you know when I
asked you the question are you gonna
grow yeah yeah I'm gonna vote but like
but but your actions yeah
we need a safety net because there's a
pause in the bodies if so it does happen
and it comes to an end we've been
advised that one big trainers is it same
everything aside everything be Jewish
yeah you don't know what it's gonna will
end tomorrow yes Megan I came all
Sunshine's yeah what's he worth yeah
what do you think
I reckon he's probably worth about 20
mil Bobby mom brain right now worth that
old idea dude yeah it's a lot it's an
old idea it's an old idea it's like you
you you have to keep expanding well it's
not about what somebody's worth or what
they make or how much they have got you
got to keep you got to keep swimming you
want to keep rolling man forget the
money forget the money you want to keep
going you're too young do you like so
what's he doing is he were dying now as
he started that that's where he's at
that's where he's at in his cycle right
so st. NSYNC a business a person you
know the this is this is a person right
their kid their eight years old dude
everything's this you know until they go
until they go to school to college and
the college actually takes this and says
okay there's four more years to just
doing nothing
it actually flattens the light out we
should have taken him out of high school
and said hey go to work right now or go
on an adventure go somewhere cuz you
don't have to keep struggling my kids at
summer camp right now she's terrified
right I can tell she's like oh my god
she's thinking about retreating coming
back down the hill yeah and I'm I won't
let she's got to be forced to go into
this thing so this guy that guy you told
me about he's probably right here this
is where you're getting his advice
okay where am I yeah I'm like and I keep
trying to extend this thing by raising
the top see so so like like where do you
get your advice when you are getting
advice from people you need in your mind
to quickly just do this where's this guy
at yeah his advice is great for this guy
yep it's brilliant advice immersive
moonship okay and also yeah yeah do you
think it's gonna be a case of choosing
to do what you've just said order need
to get to the root of the problem and
you need to get to the root of the
problem this is actually a better place
I got struggling trying to make 10,000
bucks is better than this yes
this ain't advice here dude this is
death yeah okay I would never ask that
dude for anything like like like I go
play golf with him maybe but I would
listen to him
you know I try to beat him out of every
[ __ ] penny he's got but he won't let
me but he won't let me okay
you can't get anything from I wouldn't
go to dinner with this guy you know what
cuz he's looking at the price everything
okay I'm trying to find out yeah what's
the best wine you got in here what's the
best food you got in here how can we
connect up but he's gonna be tired
before any of that happens yeah so this
is where you don't want to get your
advice until you want to be him and then
he's great he's great advice for that
guy I mean yeah but no real ads you're
not spending real money on your new at
all you should kick that up to 10 10
next your ad budget right now yeah
Facebook Instagram you when anybody puts
in anything real estate you should buy
every damn ad you got the money dude yes
you guys got the money so that's fun bro
I like you understand we put 35,000
people in a room we made less money than
if we just sold 9000 seats still better
for us oh my god every everybody in the
whole world knows I did that everybody
people in Tanzania in Zulu
Africa like Nigeria people like I never
knew know that I didn't have to spending
money in advertising all I had to do was
fill the damn event up so the biggest
event in the world I did it
somebody didn't do it for me nobody can
take that away from me ever it's worth
more than money bro
like that gets me more than because I
got ten million dollars more in my bank
account I'm having money in your bank
account it doesn't grow your business
doing things that seemed impossible grow
your business and attract talent yeah
there's a blonde blonde and a girl
walking around here right now she worked
that event for the Marlins stadium
doesn't work for the Marlins anymore and
is gonna work for us so that's how you
attract talent and that's how people
talk to you so so all I'm telling you is
like one be careful where you're getting
your advice from yeah you got to take it
with it not with a grain of salt so much
but like okay where's this cat coming
from cuz he's right - he's right for
this guy it's not that I'm more right
than he is right however you I'm gonna
go back to what Russell said Russell
says that's not what we want to do
forget the money we want to play yeah
and that's good you guys have that
figured out that's that's the other
thing you have that part figured out
your discipline with money you're not
driving roles is you're not doing stupid
stuff you fly coach over here you know
business class yeah okay did you get it
on a ticket or do rewards or miles of
what you paid cash
yeah Wow it surprises me about you boys
was it hard was it hard no no I don't
experiences hotels fly oh you loved all
that okay all right okay yeah yeah it's
brutal so what if it have been two hours
no okay good good good
soso think about you know your
advertising right now you should just go
like you should go insane on the
internet should buy ads buy the ads
promote your
your product your company never advanced
but they never really were you quit on
them cuz you quit on Google was Google
works Facebook Ads Facebook that just
attracts hires so what dude you need
haters yeah get Lennon we have them
talking about you yeah there ain't work
cuz you quit on it it's impossible for
it not to work it's impossible yeah if I
saw your ad it worked
yeah now I don't know what you're
telling people to do it's impossible for
an ad not to work people pass by here
and see my name on this building it's an
ad my flags out front that's an ad yeah
okay so how does that not work
oh that's car town I had 1 million
dollars for the billboards in in Miami
for four months okay everybody Miami saw
these I'm at Dunkin Donuts yesterday
don't I know you probably probably do
Yeah right like YouTube ads people go to
youtube they driving down the road they
look at Instagram they look at Facebook
bum bum bum they how can that hurt me
how can that not work if I do enough of
it in enough different places yeah okay
because familiarity right familiarity
over and over oh wow oh they're the guys
you could you could get on there so
we're the best real estate training
company in the world there's no one
better than us you can say that over and
over and over again yeah you know how
the President of the United States of
America make America great again I will
I'm the only person who can do it I'm
the only person who can do it
what's your policies I will make America
great again I'm the only person that can
do this well what are your policies on I
will make America great again I'm the
only person who can do it yeah all he
did was keep repeating the phrase you
should say I am the best training the
best real estate company in the world
why not dude who's going to tell you
you're not
you know I'm a big big yeah we got
thousand people a week in the room yeah
I don't know any other specific property
would you stay and prop it need in
property or would you because one of the
things with people become financially
free property I make mine a daily well
we've recently said like look you got
that you got that maybe shoot something
from the outside Johnny okay you like
this you like the setting that's a good
[ __ ] interview these guys are [ __ ]
maniacs
were you surprised how many offers I had
this thing you say stupid it was
ridiculous we look at me boy everything
yeah did it bother you did it bother you
no lucky do you know how many people in
the event business say there you can't
do that yeah too many offers too many
offers is too confusing
yeah would you bite would you buy you
bought the coaching current you about
current advertising you you have to you
have to you have to the geo-targeting
over there nobody even knows about it
yeah do do do we want to create more
promotes that's why that's why I'm
telling you the collaboration yeah yes
you need more products I mean you need
to see but but but that that takes
people I don't know that I would that's
not where I would jump this second
because it takes people and it takes you
know you don't want to be sloppy on
those products and that revenues not
your problem right now that's not where
I would go personally right now I would
kill what you're doing
I would kill what you're doing and I
would invest more I would get more money
over here so you can invest in real
estate my next product would be your
investing because it tells your story
yes you're investing the third thing
that I would do is create the business
line up later but not now not yet I
would like the business line up I would
probably collaborate with other people
to do to fulfill this I wouldn't go add
that I would collaborate and get a piece
of it
nobody had partners you hate that you
hate passing people on yeah see I know
Cece look Brant Brandon's a partner
Frank Kern's a partner but you don't
mess in the moon because that part was
listed in your world yeah I know but but
but but but Russell Brunson is a partner
yeah kind of that different world huh
well yeah different different thing
right so we try some of that if it
doesn't work again that's why as long as
you're the biggest as long as you're the
gorilla in the zoo you know as long
everybody's coming to see the gorilla
yeah the monkeys are there and and and
yeah there's some zebras to look at and
some lines and and you know there's some
birds but but everybody's coming to see
the gorillas so just be the gorilla
that's it when you go honey why would
you still take other people's money yeah
the best buy into public safe what why
why we do for someone else's money then
you've got money yourself just left this
family stripped from always well don't
all over again from scratch I think you
made it really hard this our pipe
opulent wedding this is the financial
if you would do the same challenge yeah
you starting all over again
are you happy little bit yeah what would
be your strong
[Music]
the sales way but I'm like let's talk
real estate come on